bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat hier soir les
sénateurs ont entamé l'examen du budget
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 alors c'est un texte très important
pour le gouvernement puisque c'est lui
qui met en musique le pacte de
compétitivité rappelez-vous c'est ce
texte qui avait entraîné lors de son
examen à l'Assemblée nationale un bras
de fer entre le gouvernement et une
partie des socialistes les députés
frondeurs s'opposent notamment aux
baisses de charges qui sont accordées
aux entreprises sans contrepartie en
termes d'emplois finalement l'Assemblée
nationale a voté malgré cette rébellion
le texte le 8 juillet dernier ici au
Sénat l'ambiance devrait être beaucoup
plus sereine la discussion séance
publique beaucoup moins houleuse
mercredi dernier la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat a du reste
entériné le texte même si elle a adopté
deux amendements de son rapporteur Yves
de Dini l'un de notamment qui a du reste
été à adopté à l'unanimité par cette
commission vient doubler l'abattement
des charges sociales dont bénéficie les
particuliers pour les emplois à domicile
il passerait ainsi de 75 centimes à 1,50
€ par heure supplémentaire mais tout de
suite direction l'hémicycle pour suivre
cette discussion générale sur le budget
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 très bonne matinée à tous sur notre
chaîne
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale de financement rectificatif de
la sécurité sociale pour 2014 dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Jean des Essarts
pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président
ma responsable de commission chers
collègues
le pfrs que nous examinons aujourd'hui
est une traduction du pack de
responsabilité qui définit l'objectif
économique voulu par le gouvernement
alléger le coup du travail pour relancer
l'activité
attention sans doute louable mais qui
mérite réalisation
avec les 20 milliards d'euros du cice ce
sont tal 41 milliards d'euros qui seront
ainsi accordés aux entreprises
le gouvernement estime que cette manne
financière nouvelle permettra aux
entreprises de créer 190
000 postes supplémentaires
monsieur le rapporteur l'a dit cet
après-midi le pack de responsabilité
c'est la confiance
mais la confiance
ça se construit
ça se vérifie ce n'est pas un pari
et aujourd'hui rien ne permet de
garantir que les entreprises
utiliseront ces nouvelles marges de
manœuvre pour créer des emplois
en effet l'histoire a prouvé que ces
allègements de charge profitent toujours
jusqu'à maintenant au capital plutôt
qu'au travail
une preuve entre 93 date à laquelle les
premiers allègement de charges ont été
accordées et 2013 la part de la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises allouées au
salaire et quasiment restable de 48% à
51%. tandis que la part allouée aux
dividendes à plus que doublé passant de
6% à plus de 14%
. l'impact en termes d'emploi de ces
allègements est donc peu évident et pour
financer ces allègements de charge le
gouvernement fait le choix de réduire la
dépense publique de 50 milliards d'euros
à l'horizon 2017
paradoxe comment reconnaître que la
santé la justice l'action sociale la
dépendance ont besoin de moyens de
possibles et en même temps annoncer un
plan d'économie de la dépense publique
sans précédent
nous ne sommes pas les seuls
écologiste à faire c'est analyse bien
sûr les commisses mais
également d'autres puisque selon la
direction du Trésor si les mesures du
pack devaient générer 190 000 emplois et
0,6 points de croissance cumulée à
l'horizon 2017 les 50 milliards
d'économies devraient engendrer à la
même échéance la suppression de 250 000
emplois et une baisse de croissance de
1,4 points cumulés c'est-à-dire ce qu'on
donne d'un côté qu'on croit gagner et
bien on le paie de l'autre et de façon
plus importante y compris en termes de
création d'emplois
ce PvP
ceplrss manquait
par le gel de certaines prestations
le projet initial prévoyait un gel des
aides personnalisés au logement mais un
amendement du rapporteur à l'Assemblée
nationale a supprimé cette mesure ce
dont nous nous félicitons cependant le
gel des pensions retraite supérieure à
1205 euros pendant un an et lui maintenu
ce que nous déplorons pour mémoire lors
du projet de loi sur les retraites la
revalorisation avait déjà été repoussée
de 6 mois avec cette mesure on atteint
18 mois au total sans revalorisation
ainsi ce collectif budgétaire fait le
choix de pratiquer une politique de
l'offre indifférencier tout en
fragilisant les retraités ce que nous ne
cautionnons pas
les écologistes j'aurais pas le temps de
développer propose un autre modèle
soutenir les secteurs porteurs d'avenir
comme la transition énergétique et
écologique inciter les comportements
vertueux des entreprises par des
incitations ciblées et responsables tout
en garantissant la justice sociale par
des contributions progressives dans ces
communications le gouvernement annonce
vouloir soutenir les plus modestes pour
vraiment agir leur faveur nous vous
proposons une solution plus juste et
plus efficace dans un premier temps
l'instauration d'une CSG progressive
quant aux allégements de chars sur les
basses salaires nous n'y croyons pas et
d'ailleurs un rapport qui n'a pas été
voté ce matin le confirme c'est que il y
a aucune certitude que cela crée des
emplois nous sommes opposés aux
allègements de charges sur les bas
salaires et pour réduire l'impact
négatif de ces mesures ne vous
proposerons la conditionnalité de ces
allègements ce sont des amendements de
charges pour qu'il ne soit de droit
uniquement lorsque le poste est en CDI
ou à temps complet
nous vous proposerons également une
réduction de cotisations sociales de 500
euros par mois et par apprenti pour
développer l'apprentissage nous vous
proposerons l'ouverture des emplois
d'avenir au chômeur longue durée ces
mesures temporaires jusqu'en décembre
2015 permettront de donner un coup de
pouce supplémentaire à la création
d'emploi des aides financières qui elles
auront des effets rapides et mesurables
pour l'exonération de la contribution
sociale de solidarité des sociétés nous
proposons que l'allègement bénéfique aux
entreprises qui communiquent sur la
politique de salaire de dividendes et
d'optimisation fiscale enfin nous
proposerons la suppression de gel des
retraites car elle n'est pas acceptable
que les seuls économies de ce projet de
loi soit réalisé avec la pension des
retraités
en conclusion ce plfs accorde des
faveurs des cadeaux est-ce qu'on peut
dire on verra aux entreprises sans
contrôle sans conditionnalité fragilise
les retraités réduit notre protection
sociale et en l'état il ne correspond
pas aux attentes des écologistes je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
un la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Noël
Cardou pour le groupe UMP
monsieur le Président Madame le Ministre
chers collègues vous ne serez pas
surpris cher monsieur desesseurs que mon
intervention soit radicalement
divergente de celle que vous venez de
prononcées et j'ai tendance à commencer
en disant enfin enfin après tant de
déclaration du Président de la
République et des premiers ministres
successifs sur le pack de responsabilité
et après un an de valse hésitation une
ébauche de mesure nous est enfin
présenté mais à quel prix et les
précédents intervenants illustrent
parfaitement ce propos c'est un
dispositif qui ménage la chèvre et le
chou le Medef d'un côté et l'aile gauche
de la majorité de l'autre et bien
entendu
un tel dispositif ne peut satisfaire
personne
vous proposez des exonérations de
charges sociales sur les basses salaires
1,6 fois le SMIC ce n'est en fait que
compléter bien modestement le dispositif
Fillon puisque 10 seuls disparaissent le
Front national de d'aide au logement et
la cotisation accident du travail vous
réduisez de 1,8 points la cotisation
allocation familiale mais sans poser le
problème d'une véritable réforme avec
l'opportunité d'un autre financement du
coût de la politique familiale qui ne
laisserait aux entreprises que la seule
charge des salaires de substitution
comme notre groupe en la personne de
Gérard Longuet l'a exposé dans cette
hémicycle au moment de
la défense de la motion de Serge
Dassault
vous supprimez la C3S
finançant à hauteur de 5 milliards
d'euros le RSI et le fond de solidarité
vieillesse en vous bornant à transférer
ces sommes vers le régime général et
après avoir déplafonné il y a deux ans
les cotisations retraite et maladies des
travailleurs indépendants
vous voulez rendre un peu de pouvoir
d'achat ou salariés les plus modestes
entre une fois une virgule trois fois le
SMIC en réduisant leur utilisation
sociale tout en oubliant simultanément
que vous avez supprimé la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et considérablement
alourdi leur charge d'impôts
et tout cela
ne sera applicable qu'en 2015 toujours
plus tard alors que notre économie est
exangle et que vous ne donnez aucune
indication
ce sur le financement de ces mesures
dont la c3sl représente 5 milliards
d'euros alors bien entendu
j'ai entendu des précédents orateurs en
commission notre rapporteur général
monsieur doudinier nous a dit qu'il
avait peu d'indications sur le
financement madame le ministre nous a
dit tout à l'heure que soyez tranquille
on trouvera la solution 2015 et le
rapporteur de la commission des finances
nous a dit qu'il y avait un plan c'est
quand même peu d'éléments concrets quant
au financement de ces mesures et
toujours dans la même logique et bien
c'est ce que je dise de mon propos plus
tard on verra plus tard et malgré la
baisse du rythme des dépenses de santé
vous êtes que je salue au passage vous
êtes dans l'obligation d'augmenter de
100 millions d'euros votre prévision de
déficit du régime général en raison du
ralentissement d'économie qui est la
traduction de cette politique alors
devant
ces énumérations on peut se demander
pourquoi
ce projet de loi rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale maintenant les
précédents intervenants ont parfaitement
soulignés que c'était un phénomène
exceptionnel puisque depuis presque 20
ans
une démarche qui n'est intervenue que
deux fois donc deux fois on pourrait
imaginer que ce soit pour un événement
considérable qu'il convenait de
présenter au parlementaire avant l'été
et bien pardonnez-moi d'employé une
expression assez prosaïque mais ça fait
pshites puisque en fait on nous annonce
en juillet 2014 des mesures qui ne sont
applicables qu'à partir de 2015 et on ne
nous dit pas comment cela est financé
donc je pense qu'on aurait pu économiser
ce débat et puis le repousser au moment
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale à l'automne ça aurait
été beaucoup plus logique alors en
revanche les seules données financières
claires que vous
alors je dirais que nous sommes loin du
choc de compétitivité si nécessaire à la
France
dans notre esprit la seule solution
serait de lancer des signes forts dans
les secteurs qui en ont le plus besoin
et en premier lieu les services à la
personne et les emplois à domicile le
secrétaire d'État monsieur Hecker
déclarait récemment que
la réduction de cotisations devait être
fixée par des grès et qu'il envisageait
une modulation d'abattement pour revenir
sur la suppression du calcul au forfait
il y a quelques mois qui pouvaient être
comprise entre 0,75 euros jusqu'à 2
euros notre rapporteur est d'ailleurs je
salue le fait que cet amendement ce
projet d'amendement a été adopté à
l'unanimité par le Commission a proposé
un abattement d'un euro 50 mais nous
voudrions aller plus loin au moins 2
euros voire rétablir en partie le
système du calcul au forfait il faudrait
aussi étant exonérations de charge des
entreprises en particulier qui est celle
d'allocations familiale au revenu
représentant trois ou quatre fois le
SMIC ce qui donnerait un coup de fouet
salutaire aux entreprises innovantes et
aux startups et on sait très bien que
ces entreprises qui exportent qui font
preuve de beaucoup d'imagination sont
défavorisés dans la compétition mondiale
et limiter par le bas ces exonérations
les pénalyses considérablement Madame le
Ministre pendant le débat à la
commission vous nous avez dit ce sera
fait en 2016 ou en 2017 et je dis plus
tard toujours plus tard toujours plus
tard il faudrait aussi c'est pas tout à
fait le débat du jour mais cela en fait
partie
réviser le cice pour qu'il soit
accessible à cette catégorie
d'entreprises que je viens de décrire
startup entreprise innovante parce
qu'actuellement nous savons très bien
qui bénéficie essentiellement à des
entreprises qui ne sont pas
délocalisables les grandes surfaces la
poste alors qu'en fait ce sont les
entreprises qui exportent et qui
auraient besoin de ce coup de pouce et
nous revenons
encore un interrogation ou une
suggestion sur le financement de ces
mesures et nous préconisons cette TVA
antidélocalisation que vous avez
supprimé mais qui refait son chemin
progressivement dans l'esprit d'ailleurs
notre apporteur nous a dit oui
peut-être peut-être
pas plus loin mais c'est quelque chose
qui continue de faire son chemin et je
crois qu'il faudrait faire
un effort de d'études à ce sujet là
parce qu'il suffit pas dire on augmente
de 2 ou 3 points la TVA il faut avoir
des augmentations de TVA ciblées et
avoir des augmentations très sensibles
sur certains produits de haut niveau sur
un produit importé je pense aux voitures
4x4 on pourra en faire aussi une TVA
favorisant la fiscalité logique
écologique mais tout le monde sait bien
que c'est la solution est d'ailleurs
j'en veux pour preuve que les ministres
des Finances de la zone euro très
récemment le 7 juillet on recommandé
l'allégement de fiscalité sur le travail
qui serait compensé je cite entre
guillemets par des sources de revenus
fiscaux moins préjudiciables à la
croissance comme des taxes sur la
cosmotion c'est une phrase que très
modestement j'aurais bien pu reprendre à
mon compte mais c'est la collégialité
des ministres des Finances de la zone
euro qui la prononcée alors voyez chers
collègues je vous rassure j'aurais
utilisé qu'une partie de mon temps de
parole mais pour terminer
c'est pas méchant ce que je vais dire
mais c'est quand même je pense assez
réaliste
je voudrais j'aimerais vous donner une
définition parmi d'autres que j'ai
trouvé de l'autodestruction
le comportement autour destructeur est
une sorte d'autopunition en réponse à un
échec personnel il est souvent motivé
par un besoin d'attention
et je pense qu'avec ce texte et les
textes qui vont venir qui sont passés
que nous sommes un peu au cœur du
problème parce que on nous propose des
textes qui bien souvent
sont des textes d'affichage je l'ai dit
mais qui reviennent sur des mesures que
vous avez même voté vous-même votez il y
a quelques temps alors c'est tendance à
dire après avoir minutieusement et
laborieusement des tricoté tout ce
qu'avait fait le précédent gouvernement
et bien vous commencez à détricoter ce
que vous avez vous-même enclenché c'est
quand même le comble et je prendrai
simplement quelques exemples des emplois
d'avenir on en a déjà parlé j'avais fait
cette allusion devant Monsieur sapin un
certain moment les emplois d'avenir qui
timidement vont s'ouvrir au monde de
l'entreprise le temps partiel qui pose
d'énormes problèmes on l'avait bien
souligné lors du de la loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi la pénibilité
la pénibilité qui a été la pomme de
discorde avec les partenaires sociaux il
y a peu de temps et diocèse si dans
cette hémicycle au moment de la loi sur
le retraites nous avions multiplié les
mises en garde conclusive en garde un
usine à gaz pardon que ce compte
pénibilité pouvait faire vous êtes en
train de revenir tout doucement en
arrière la loi alur n'en parlons pas et
qui est un frein considérable à la
construction de logements et puis
bientôt ça c'est le dernier né le
président République à lui-même annoncé
et bien on va revenir sur les mesures
néfastes contre l'apprentissage que vous
aviez vous-même voté et lors du débat
sur la formation professionnelle nous
avions aussi fortement ciblé ce problème
en disant que vous étiez en train de
sacrifier l'apprentissage alors bien sûr
vous revenez tout doucement dessus mais
pourtant nous avions tiré la sonnette
d'alarme nous n'avons pas été entendu et
nous le regrettons alors ma conclusion
sera de dire et bien vous commencez à
réagir
c'est bien mais pas assez vite et pas ce
vigoureusement bien sûr on n'est pas
d'accord avec une partie de votre
majorité mais je crois que il faut aller
encore plus loin et créer ce véritable
choc dont la France a tellement besoin
voilà pourquoi et ce sera ma conclusion
notre groupe s'abstiendra sur la partie
recette de ce texte qui malgré ses
insuffisances est un timide premier pas
dans la bonne direction et puis nous
souhaitons que le débat Aya son terme
donc nous verrons après quand cette
première partie sera passée et bien
qu'elle sera notre position sur le texte
final mais je crains malheureusement que
nous soyons contraints de nous y opposer
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur Gérard roche
pour le groupe udius
ce président madame la ministre madame
la Présidente de la Commission sur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
pourquoi une loi de rectificative en
2014 alors qu'elle ne s'appliquera qu'en
nous attendions une réforme structurelle
et nous avons un chèque en blanc
oui c'est bien cela que qui peut
s'apparenter à quoi je peux ça peut
s'apparenter le présente le présentexte
un chèque en blanc est plus pressé plus
précisément un double chèque en blanc
c'est d'une part entre le Parlement et
le gouvernement et d'autre part par le
gouvernement aux entreprises premier
volet de ce chèque en blanc donc celui
que l'on nous demande de signer
aujourd'hui à nous parlementaire en
effet ce PLF fait SS c'est de redire
dépense sans compensées il met en oeuvre
l'essentiel des mesures de relance du
pacte de responsabilité de solidarité
mais sans que nous n'ayons aucune idée
de la manière dont les pertes de
recettes engendrées pour la protection
sociale seront financés
seuls les mesures relatives à l'impôt
sur les sociétés et à l'impôt sur le
revenu relève du champ du loi des lois
de finance autrement dit 70% des
dépenses nouvelles du pacte relève du
champ des lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale donc du projet
rectificatif d'où son importance
politique
mais aussi symbolique pour le
gouvernement
notre point de vue de parlementaire
comment voter sans avoir une vision
d'ensemble du dispositif envisagé pour
2014 et 2015 le PLF RSS progresse
programme 9 milliards d'euros de
recettes en moins pour seulement 1,3
milliards d'économies donc ce n'est pas
moins de 7,7 milliards de recettes que
nous sommes censés accepter sans savoir
comment elles seront financées j'ai bien
entendu notre collègue Jean-Pierre café
nous détaillait des mesures que nous
connaissions déjà en partie Madame le
Ministre pour you confirmer ce qui vient
d'être dit car dans votre propos vous
étiez plutôt replié sur la loi organique
et ordinaire de 2015
madame le ministre nous ne doutons pas
une seule seconde que les pertes de
recettes pour la protection sociale
seront compensées par le budget de
l'État y compris la perte des recettes
liées à l'extension progressive de la
citroëns mais c'est repoussé le problème
circuler pour mieux sauter ces dépenses
vont donc poser sur le budget d'État
comment ils seront-elles compensés
économie ou recettes nouvelles quel mix
des deux pour l'heure nous ne savons pas
d'où le sentiment que nous avons de
passé à côté de la réforme majeure dans
notre pays atteint un besoin et depuis
si longtemps cette réforme qui
consisterait à profiter de l'engagement
des charges sur le travail pour les
compenser de deux manières d'une part
par des économies budgétaires
structurelles d'autre part par la
fiscalisation du financement de la
protection sociale
nous pouvons donc approuver les
allègements nous les appelons de nos
vœux depuis longtemps parce que ce n'est
pas un secret pour personne le
financement de la protection sociale
pèse aujourd'hui bien trop lourdement
sur la production le dernier rapport
annuel de la Commission sur évolution de
la fiscalité de l'Union européenne là
encore rappelé il faut donc décharger le
travail ce que font les deux premiers
articles du PLF RSS mais s'ils le font
encore selon nous de manière
insuffisante ils vont dans le bon sens à
terme nous pensons que c'est la totalité
des cotisations familles qui ont
vocation disparaître et certains d'entre
nous s'interrogent même sur le devenir
des cotisations maladie dans les
décennies à lire
à terme
cela suppose de réaliser des économies
budgétaires structurelles mais où sont
les économies
pour leur la seule qui nous a été
proposée c'est la réforme territoriale
la suppression de l'Assemblée
dépassementale or quand on sait ce que
ce ne sont pas les structures du conseil
général qui coûtent cher mais l'émission
dont il est investi on s'interroge sur
le gain budgétaire et pendant ce
temps-là sur le terrain déjà en cétone
d'apprendre qu'un sous-préfet peut être
plus important qu'un président de
conseil général mais excusez-moi
je suis hors sujet mais c'est
obsessionnel chez moi
pour financer structurer le main la
baisse des charges il faut également
fiscaliser le financement de la
protection sociale tout en évitant des
impôts de production qui ne feraient que
reproduire le problème posé par les
charges sociales
raison pour laquelle nous soutenons
aussi la suppression de la C3S mais sur
la masse des besoins de financement la
suppression de cette contribution
demeure anecdotique alors cette réforme
fiscale
allez-vous le gouvernement d'amener à
bien madame le ministre sans doute au
moins en partie mais il nous faut le
dire parce que pour l'heure la seule
mesure de financement figurant dans
présentextes et le gel des pensions de
retraite de l'article 9 heureusement
vous avez annoncé au gel des aides au
logement cela aurait été très choquant
heureusement vous semblait avoir renoncé
au chef des rentes d'invalidité de la
TMP d'ailleurs madame le ministre il y
avait vraiment renoncé notre hotte
assemblée
puis en 2015 des allocations familiales
des mesures en totale disproportion
financière par rapport aux besoins je ne
reviens pas là dessus mais aussi des
mesures inacceptables sur le plan de
l'équité sur le plan humain vous nous
dites qu'il est juste de ne pas
revaloriser les pensions de 1200 euros
brut et plus madame la ministre je vous
connais un peu
vous pouvez pas nous dire qu'il est
juste de ne pas revaloriser les pensions
à partir de 1200 euros brut comme nous
savions que c'est
2200 euros brut par mois peuvent faire
vivre récemment une famille ou des gens
qui sont dans la peine et pourtant
gouvernement avait donné des exemples on
peut approuver la réduction dégressive
des cotisations salariales pour des
revenus inférieurs ou égaux à un tiers
du SMIC dans le privé on avait été un
peu choqué de voir que une certaine
disparité avec la fonction publique
puisque ce dégrèvement touchait les
revenus inférieurs ou égaux à 1,16 mi
mais j'ai lu un tactilement le rapport
de la commission des finances et j'ai eu
la réponse
de plus
il faut pour prendre des mesures
fiscales courageuses
et de bon sens
elles sont envisageables 1,5 points de
TVA ou trois quarts de points CSG
couvriraient les 9 milliards d'euros de
dépenses du pacte responsabilité de
solidarité pour 2014 et 2015 la CSG
présente l'avantage d'être un impôts au
Togo et à l'assiette large la TVA
présente l'avantage de taxer les
importations qui représentent tout de
même 30% du PIB elle ferait donc
participer à l'étranger au financement
de la protection sociale française de
plus
traditionnellement présenté comme un
impôts à juste elle est aujourd'hui
beaucoup moins dans la mesure où les
produits de première nécessité dont on
sait qu'il représente une part bien plus
importante du panier de consommation des
ménages ports par rapport aux ménagésés
sont assujettis autour réduits
pour leur le gouvernement il semble
pourtant toujours réfractaire
j’évoquais en ouverture le chèque en
blanc
en évoquant en parlant de second volet
celui que le gouvernement signe lui-même
au bénéfice des entreprises parce que
les baisses de charge patronales qui
représentent l'essentiel du dispositif
ne sont conditionnés à rien alors qu'au
départ la parole présidentielle semblait
indiquer le contraire donc posons la
question qui est sans doute la plus
importante les baisses de charge
auraient-elles dû être conditionnées à
des embauches historiquement elles n'ont
jamais été fallait-il le faire
aujourd'hui peut-être à vrai dire nous
un peu réservé sur cette date car
s'aspect de Cheikh kamelan est trop
inévitable attention ce n'est pas un
problème technique l'octroi des
allègements serait conditionné à
l'évolution de l'effectif des
entreprises c'est facile mais sur le
fond il serait impossible dans ces
conditions de distinguer les effets
d'aubaine des véritables embauches liés
au bénéfice des allégements
un effet d'autant plus probable que les
entreprises françaises sont actuellement
aujourd'hui en surcapacité d'emplois le
système ne résoudrait donc rien puisque
les entreprises ou renonceraient aux
allègements de charge ou créer des
emplois non productifs ce qui
n'améliorerait en rien leur
compétitivité au contraire le véritable
objet des allègements de charge et de
créer une dynamique vertueuse
véritablement économique il s'agit de
restaurer les marges des entreprises
pour qu'elle développe leur activité et
créer de l'emploi directement ou
indirectement pour leur par leur
consommation mais alors ne mentons pas
aux Français il ne peut s'agir d'emplois
immédiats mais d'emploi pour le futur
pour que cet effet remporte il faut que
les gains générés par les allègements et
principalement à la rémunération du
facteur travail c'est-à-dire à la masse
salariale soit sous forme d'augmentation
de salaire soit sous forme d'embauche ou
à l'investissement de l'entreprise pour
améliorer son outil de production mais
pas la rémunération du capital
c'est-à-dire des actionnaires sauf
sauf dans les cas spécifiques
l'ouverture de capital en effet dans ces
derniers cas les perspectives
d'amélioration de la rémunération du
capital peuvent générer un effet de
levier vertueux pour faciliter l'élever
de fonds et permettre ainsi à
l'entreprise d'investir dans ces
conditions plutôt qu'un mécanisme
sanction consistant lié les baisses de
charges à la gauche ne peut-on imaginer
mettre en place un mécanisme consistant
supprimer les allègements de charge ou
créer des amendes correspondantes pour
les entreprises qui n'auront pas joué le
jeu c'est-à-dire les employés qui ont
principalement employés le gain des
allègement à rémunérer les actionnaires
Madame le Ministre que pensez-vous d'une
telle piste est-elle à l'étude par
ailleurs même dans l'hypothèse ou le
gain des allègements de charge serait
correctement employés à la rémunération
du facteur travail ou en investissement
il ne produira le maximum de ses effets
de relance que si cela se traduit par
une baisse de l'importation et c'est là
que je vais en venir pour terminer je
vais en venir à la TVA sociale qui seul
peut limiter cet effet alors la boucle
est bouclée le binôme allègement de
charge associé à la TVA sociale et donc
bien à nos yeux un binôme indissociable
sincèrement je crois madame la ministre
que c'est une erreur de persister la
dissocier je ne suis je n'ai bien sûr
pas la prétention de vous avoir
convaincu et j'adore changer vos
orientations mais notre vote indépendra
naturellement merci de votre attention
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Madame Christiane de
montez pour le groupe socialiste
voici le président madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de commission
messieurs les rapporteurs yvelodynier
Jean-Pierre cafe mes chers collègues
excusez-moi Melton va changer nous
allons soutenir ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour 2014 alors c'est vrai
la situation dans laquelle s'inscrit ce
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative pour 2014
est difficile nous le savons tous nous
le voyons tous les jours ce texte
s'inscrit dans la logique de
redressement dans la justice de notre
pays
initiée depuis 2012
joie juin pardon à la loi de finances
rectificative il constitue la première
étape de mise en oeuvre du pacte de
responsabilité de solidarité lequel
répond à l'engagement pris par le
Président de la République le 14 janvier
dernier à l'exigence de trouver de
nouveaux moyens dédiés à l'emploi à
l'investissement au renforcement de
compétitivité de nos entreprises et
évidemment à la croissance ce texte
revêt donc une importance particulière
rationnelle il prend le possible en
considération notamment au regard de la
situation de nos comptes publics ainsi
que du déficit structurel de
compétitivité dont souffre notre
économie et d'ailleurs depuis de
nombreuses années et bien avant 2012 il
est l'expression de ce pacte de
responsabilité de solidarité qui repose
sur un triptyque alliant compétitivité
avec la politique de la fiscalité sur
les entreprises qui abaissera le coût du
travail
responsabilité avec un plan d'économie
de 50 milliards d'euros sur trois ans ce
qui nous permettra de respecter la
trajectoire budgétaire des finances
publiques et enfin solidarité avec les
dispositions soutenant le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens
sur la forme vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
madame la ministre j'observe que le 24
juin dernier la Cour des comptes a
certifié la sincérité l'exactitude des
comptes de chacune des branches du
régime général de la sécurité sociale et
de chacune des caisses nationales qui
les pilotent ce qui m'échappe et sans
précédent ceci est bien l'illustration
du fait que la politique engagée depuis
2012 donne des résultats positifs cette
politique a d'ailleurs généré la baisse
des déficits sociaux je voudrais me
rappeler mes chers collègues de ce côté
du de l'hémicycle qu'il s'élevait ses
déficits de socio à 17,4 milliards
d'euros en 2011 ils sont aujourd'hui de
12,5 milliards d'euros en 2013 en 2010
alors que la croissance atteignait
1,6%, le déficit des comptes sociaux
avait progressé de
4,5 milliards d'euros pour atteindre 28
milliards d'euros en 2013 avec une
croissance d'appel
01%, le déficit recule de 2 milliards
d'euros
en outre ce sérieux budgétaire c'est
accompagné d'un souci de justice car il
n'y a pas eu de remise en cause de la
protection sociale de nos concitoyens je
vous rappellerai aucun nouveau des
remboursements n'est intervenu depuis
2012 aucune création de forfait
supplémentaire à titre de comparaison en
2010 la dette de la Cadès était étalée
alors que l'autorisation de découverte
de la cosse passait vous vous en
souvenez mes chers collègues de 70 à 130
milliards d'euros le système des
retraites est pérennisé et des avancées
notables ont été réalisées j'en
rappellerai 3 les carrières longues
mesure de justice s'il en est nous avons
vu à l'invitation de madame la ministre
il y a quelques semaines des retraités
de 60 ans qui avaient commencé à
travailler à 15 16 17 ans et il était
bien normal que cela puisse partir en
ayant leur nombre d'années de
cotisations
reconnaissance de la pénibilité qu'il
avait fait avant nous cette
reconnaissance de la pénibilité et enfin
mesure extrêmement importante prise en
compte des durées de maternité pour les
femmes puisqu'on sait qu'en matière de
retraite l'inégalité entre les hommes et
les femmes est toujours en réel de même
des progrès ont été faits ils étaient
attendus ainsi pour de nombreuses
familles modestes la revalorisation de
25% de la location de rentrée scolaire
celle du complément familial et de la
location de soutien familial l'extension
de la CMUC de l'aide à la complémentaire
santé je vous rappelle que 750 000
personnes auront une complémentaire
gratuite ou aider ce sérieux budgétaire
ce sens des responsabilités va nous
permettre de donner naissance à une
véritable politique de santé publique
telle que vous nous l'avez annoncé
madame la ministre sur le fond ce texte
financier entend renforcé la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et par
extension de
première des priorités pour ce faire et
alors que nous assistons à la montée en
charge du Crédit Impôt compétitivité
emploi une série de dispositions sont
prises il s'agit de l'augmentation des
allèlements généraux pour 4,5 milliards
d'euros en 2015 la mesure de l'article 2
inscrit l'exonération des cotisations
pour les salariés entre 1 et 1,6 Migu et
bénéficiera avant tout au PMA qui sont
les moteurs de l'emploi et de la
croissance ainsi dès le premier janvier
2015 au niveau du SMIC le zéro
cotisation patronale URSSAF sera
effectif à cela ajoutons la baisse du
taux des cotisations familiales de 5 à
2,25% en faveur des travailleurs
indépendants pour près d'un milliard
d'euros enfin est acté la première étape
de suppression de la contribution
sociale de solidarité des sociétés
toucher trois s sous la forme d'un
abattement exonérant ainsi nombre de
petites et moyennes entreprises le
second pan de ce texte consacre la
volonté de conforter la justice sociale
et le pouvoir d'achat dès janvier
prochain
Sora mis en oeuvre en allégement
dégressif des cotisations salariales
pour les salaires inférieurs à 1,3 SMIC
et je suis très surprise d'entendre
aujourd'hui certains sur ces banques qui
voudraient qu'on aille plus loin alors
qu'il n'avait rien fait au moment où ils
étaient au pouvoir cette mesure de
l'article premier concerne
5,2 millions de salariés du privé qui
verront leur pouvoir d'achat augmenter
de plus de 500 euros par an s'ajoute une
mesure
identique qui sera prise pour les
différentes fonctions publiques sur la
base du traitement indiciaire brut et ça
jusqu'à 1,5
de fonctionnaires civils et militaires
qui seront ainsi concernés pour un coût
évalué à 1,5 milliards d'euros ces
mesures complètent la disposition de la
loi de finances rectificative visant à
réduire l'impôt sur le revenu pour 3,7
millions de nos concitoyens pour un
montant de plus d'un milliard d'euros
soit une baisse de 350 euros pour un
célibataire dans cette logique de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat et en
cohérence avec les revalorisations de
l'aide personnalisé au logement et de
l'allocation de logement social votez là
aussi dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances rectificative l'allocation de
logements familial la LF est aussi
revalorisée s'ajoutent à cela le fait
que les retraites d'un montant inférieur
à 1200 euros
bénéficieront elle aussi de cette
réévaluation alors que les autres seront
bloqués pendant un an je rappelle que ça
concerne 50% des retraités de notre pays
ce PLFSS rectificatif contient aussi les
premières mesures du plan d'économie ces
dispositions viennent compléter les
efforts réalisés par nos administrations
afin de frire le meilleur service tout
en en contrôlant le coup le volume
d'économie visée est important et le
concours des prestations sociales y
participent néanmoins l'effort demandé
progressif et l'absence exceptionnelle
de revalorisation des prestations ne
concernera ni les ménages modestes ni
comme nous l'avons vu la moitié de nos
retraités
pour conclure je voudrais madame la
ministre vous faire part d'un certain
nombre de craintes mais je sais que vous
les partagez la première elle concerne
la branche vieillesse ou plus
particulièrement l'évolution du Fonds de
solidarité vieillesse
le fond de solidarité vieillesse c'est
le miroir de la pauvreté de la précarité
de ceux et de sel qui sont
définitivement sortis du marché de
l'emploi et ils sont effectivement
nombreux et donc le volume financier du
Fonds de solidarité vieillesse augmente
progresse ce qui doit bien évidemment
mobiliser toute notre vigilance la
seconde crainte que je voudrais évoquer
c'est celle qui est liée à la politique
de baisse de cotisation sur les bas
salaires pour favoriser l'accès à
l'emploi et pour favoriser
le recrutement par les entreprises nous
savons bien qu'il existe un risque de
création d'une trappe à bas salaire avec
ses exonérations de cotisations donc là
aussi il nous faut être vigilant il est
donc heureux que l'alinéa 48 de
l'article 2 prévoit la mise en place au
sein de la négociation annuelle de
branches sur les salaires d'une év de
l'impact du facteur de responsabilité et
en particulier des exonérations de
cotisations patronales mais également du
cice sur l'emploi et sur les salaires
pour conclure mon propos et d'autres
collègues interviendront après moi je
considère nous considérons que ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative est un texte
responsable
économiquement socialement et
politiquement marquer du saut de la
justice il s'inscrit dans la logique et
l'exigence du redressement de notre pays
et apporte des réponses complémentaires
et appropriées à la question centrale de
l'emploi alors bien sûr madame la
ministre je l'ai dit au début de mon
intervention le groupe socialiste votera
ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative et le
votera avec fierté mesdames et messieurs
je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur renoncerdraon
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales messieurs les
rapporteurs Yves daudignies et
Jean-Pierre cafe mes chers collègues ce
pélafer de la sécurité sociale s'inscrit
comme la première étape de mise en œuvre
du pacte de responsabilité de solidarité
qui était l'une des priorités voulues
par le président François Hollande
priorité confirmée par le Premier
ministre la vocation de ce pacte de
proposer des mesures ciblées comme des
baisses de prélèvement des exonérations
en faveur des plus modestes mais
également en faveur des entreprises je
veux à ce sujet saluer les premiers
résultats de la politique de réduction
des déficits sociaux menés depuis
maintenant deux ans par votre
gouvernement
néanmoins la réduction du déficit public
ne doit nullement nous faire revoir à la
baisse notre politique de protection
sociale nous devons offrir à l'ensemble
de la population tout en prenant en
compte les contraintes économiques du
moment une politique ambitieuse
solidaire et responsable ainsi que la
dit Christiane de mon test à l'instant
cette politique est plus que nécessaire
car les personnes touchées pour la
pauvreté sont de plus en plus nombreuses
et surtout de plus en plus pauvres et
les prestations sociales constituent une
protection et remplaçable l'emploi nous
le savons tous ici la priorité des
Français aussi la première étape du
pacte est dirigée vers les entreprises
au travers des articles 2 et 3 du
présent projet de loi l'ambition et de
redonné aux entreprises la capacité de
faire face à la concurrence grâce à la
légende du coût du travail mais aussi
par la simplification des procédures
administratives l'allègement des
cotisations et la baisse du coût du
travail devrait effectivement inciter à
la création d'emplois mais je reste
intimement convaincu que ces mesures
importantes prises en faveur des
entreprises peut-être accompagné de
garanties confirmant la création
d'emplois le second engagement est bien
entendu le plan d'économie de 50
milliards d'euros qui s'appliquera au
finances de l'État aux collectivité et
la sécurité sociale ainsi ce projet de
loi propose de mettre en place des
mesures destinées à corriger l'équilibre
des comptes sociaux je tiens d'ailleurs
à souligner l'initiative de nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale
concernant l'article 9 qui prévoyait le
gel des aides au logement en effet le
logement est-ce qu'il pèse le plus
aujourd'hui dans le budget d'aménage et
au regard des conditions de vie précaire
des bénéficiaires de ces aides ils ont
décidé de supprimer le gel de
l'allocation de logement je m'en
félicite
les inégalités s'accroissent et les
conséquences sociales sont parfois
dramatiques
il est de notre devoir de promouvoir une
politique solidaire garant de notre
système de protection sociale les
Français concentrent depuis des années à
de très lourds efforts aussi nous devons
mes chers collègues trouver un juste
équilibre entre réduction des déficits
tout en maintenant un haut niveau de
protection François Mitterrand lui
disait l'égalité n'est jamais acquise
c'est toujours un combat et ce combat
madame la ministre nous savons que vous
le menez
les dispositifs du projet de loi de
finances rectificative et ceux du projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale doivent être à analysés
de façon simultanée et cohérente
Jean-Pierre cafe la excellente dit cet
après-midi ici à la tribune j'aimerais à
cet égard parler de l'amendement que
j'avais présenté lors du PLFR et que je
représente aujourd'hui par le biais d'un
article additionnel et qui concerne
l'exonération transport même si cela
peut apparaître hors sujet
le système d'exonération du versement
transport fait actuellement l'objet
d'amendement dans deux projets de voie
de distincts le PLFR et la loi ESF ces
modifications génèrent des risques
financiers et juridiques pour les aoter
qui pourrait être évité en clarifiant le
contenu des amendements en effet pour
bénéficier d'une exonération une
association ou une fondation doit en
faire la demande à laetée celle-ci
contrôle que l'organisme remplit les
trois conditions à savoir la
reconnaissance d'utilité publique le
fait d'être à but non lucratif et
l'activité à caractère social et si tu
as le cas elle accorde obligatoirement
l'exonération par une délibération
la contradiction entre les deux
amendements nécessite un choix pour
assurer la cohérence de la loi soit
choisir l'amendement réservant
l'exonération aux entreprises solidaires
d'utilité sociale soit choisir
l'amendement élargissant l'exonération
actuelle et dans ce cas une sécurisation
des conditions d'application est
indispensable pour limiter le nombre de
recours aussi l'amendement que je
présente se base sous la proposition
exprimée dans le projet de loi relatif à
l'ESS qui vise à exonérer les
associations et fondations lorsque
celle-ci bénéficie de l'agrément
entreprise solidaire d'utilité sociale
actualisée à l'article 7 du même projet
de loi il s'applique également au centre
de lutte contre le cancer qui ne sont
pas couverts par les dispositions du
projet de loi sur le SS
cette solution permettrait d'éteindre
les risques de contentieux entre
associations et à ôté puisque seul
l'existence de l'agrément permet à
l'association de se prévaloir d'une
exonération par ailleurs grâce aux
conditions à réunir pour obtenir
l'agrément cette solution permettrait de
concilier le soutien au secteur de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et la
préservation de la situation financière
des aoûtés dans un contexte financier
très tendu pour une grande partie
d'entre elles
je m'arrêterai là ce projet de loi en
conclusion marque le point de départ du
pacte responsabilité de solidarité pour
je dois baser sur la compétitivité sur
la responsabilité et surtout sur la
solidarité l'équilibre est délicat nous
le savons il nous faut veiller à
soutenir le plus possible les personnes
les plus précaires et nous savons
socialistes que tel est votre objectif
madame la ministre je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Alina chaimbaud pour le groupe
écologie
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis chers collègues
madame la ministre je vous le dis
d'emblée nous partageons votre volonté
de diminuer la dette de la sécurité
sociale pour assurer la pérennité de
notre système de solidarité nationale
mais nous ne partageons pas votre vision
de la manière dont il faut réduire ses
dépenses publiques qui devraient passer
selon nous
en développant d'autres priorités en
matière de santé publique nous craignons
que les mesures proposées dans ce texte
l'hypothèque l'avenir la sécurité
sociale et voudrions relayer auprès de
vous madame la ministre l'inquiétude des
professionnels de santé publique des
travailleurs sociaux qui se demandent où
les coupes vont être faites les
allègements de cotisations salariales
proposées par ce pllf RSS 10.000 euros
en effet ça a déjà été dit les recettes
de la sécurité sociale de deux et demi
milliards d'euros les allègements des
cotisations patronales et travailleurs
indépendants de 5 milliards et demi
d'euros l'abaissement d'assiettes la
contribution sociale solidarité des
sociétés d'un milliard d'euros cela fait
en tout 9 milliards d'euros toutes ces
mesures constituent des diminutions
pérennes des recettes de la sécurité
sociale sans que nous soient données
clairement aujourd'hui les moyens
pérennes qui seront parallèlement mis en
oeuvre car nous nous ont imaginé que le
gel de certaines prestations sociales
que vous proposez cette année et qui
d'ailleurs ne compense que très
partiellement les sommes en jeu soit
reconduits d'années en année pour
équilibrer nos comptes publics je crains
que les mesures proposées ici ne soit de
mauvaises solutions qui ne mettent en
péril l'équilibre financier de notre
système de solidarité nationale oui nous
pensons qu'une autre vision des
questions de santé pourraient amener
tout autant d'économies et des économies
durables pour faire des économies non
écologistes proposons de dépenser
autrement c'est-à-dire d'augmenter
beaucoup plus les dépenses
d'investissement dans l'accès à la santé
celles qui permettent à court à moyen et
à long terme de faire des économies donc
c'est le dans cette logique je ne
comprends par exemple pas pourquoi
l'adoption de mesure durables pour
lutter contre la pollution de l'air
prend tant de temps alors que celle-ci
coûte chaque année ce sont les chiffres
du commissariat général au développement
durable de l'année 2012 coûte chaque
année entre 30 et 50 milliards d'euros à
la sécurité sociale je ne comprends pas
non plus pourquoi bientôt un an après la
remise de mon rapport sur l'accès aux
soins des plus démunis les mesures de
simplification de l'accès au droit
prennent tant de temps à être mis en
œuvre alors que même le secrétariat
général pour la modernisation de
l'action publique le
conçu pour tenir le rôle de conseil
auprès du gouvernement dans
l'élaboration la conduite le suivi du
programme global de réforme explique
quand s'attaquant aux obstacles qui
constituent ce parcours du combattant de
l'accès aux soins on améliore l'état de
santé globale de la population et que
cela dégage un gisement d'économie
qu'ils appellent d'ailleurs je cite le
gisement moins de maladies pour mémoire
un certain nombre de propositions sont
faites rendre automatique l'attribution
de la couverture maladie universelle
complémentaire au bénéficiaire du Revenu
de Solidarité Active une autre
proposition fondée l'attribution de la
CMU complémentaire et de la CS sur le
dernier revenu fiscal de référence
c'est-à-dire simplifier considérablement
l'accès à ses droits qui du coup en
permettant un accès plus facile à la
santé serait un investissement et
produirait des économies très
importantes beaucoup le disent je ne
comprends pas non plus pourquoi
vous continuez à refuser les mesures de
santé environnementale que nous
proposons plfs après PLFSS lorsqu'on
sait le poids de d'un certain nombre
d'épidémies comme le cancer ou d'autres
qui ont en partie on le sait des causes
environnementales et qui coûtent très
cher au budget de la Sécurité sociale
pourquoi par ailleurs a-t-on perdu
autant de temps sur la question épineuse
des refus de soins qui éloignent
durablement de notre système de santé
des personnes précaires ou gravement
malade que l'on retrouve dans un état
très aggravé plus tard dans nos services
d'urgence encombrés et dont la prise en
charge coûtera en conséquence finalement
beaucoup plus cher là encore pourquoi
prévoir dans l'axe 13-1 du plan cancer
de dépenser dès maintenant des centaines
de millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
le Gardasil alors que ce vaccin est de
plus en plus contesté ne faudrait-il pas
au minimum pour cette année un moratoire
sur toute mesure nouvelle d'incitation à
ce vaccin au moins le temps de mener une
étude indépendante sur le sujet alors au
lieu de tout cela vous nous proposez des
mesures qui apparaissent en l'état et
Jean disait ça la rappeler tout à
l'heure un chèque en blanc aux
entreprises parce que il n'y a pas en
face des garanties que tout cela va
aboutir à la création d'emplois donc ce
sont des mesures qui sont sans
conditionnalité et qui nous paraissent
tout à fait déséquilibré nous allons
défendre un certain nombre d'amendements
mais en l'état actuel du texte nous ne
pouvons pas le voter je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Georges la base
et pour le groupe socialiste
chez le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues m'ont propos sera bref
il vise à compléter l'intervention de
mon collègue roman cadran sous un angle
plus médico-social
souvenez-vous
roland-gargan la rappeler à l'instant
lorsque nous avons examiné le projet de
loi relatif à l'économie sociale et
solidaire nous avons avec l'Assemblée
nationale adoptée une mesure permettant
de préserver
l'exonération du versement de transport
dans les associations et fondations
bénéficier depuis plus de 50 ans
le projet de loi des finances
rectificative à supprimer cette
exonération
lourde conséquence pour le secteur
médico-social
et c'est pour cela que je me permets de
vous en parler durant l'examen de ce
projet de loi rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale en effet les
associations et autres fondations du
secteur sanitaire
secteur sanitaire social et
médico-social qui accompagnent au
quotidien les citoyens les plus
vulnérables personne handicapées
personne
exclu ou âgées vont devoir payer à
présent cette taxe cela représente
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
et donc l'équivalent de milliers
d'emplois
je rappelle que ces mêmes associations
ont déjà été exclues du cice
venir à présent alourdir leur charges et
sans concertation aucune c'est tout
simplement dramatique
je vous rappelle chers collègues que
l'année 2014 a été déclarée Grande cause
nationale pour l'engagement associatif
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre je
vous demande de permettre aux
associations agréées
sous le label entreprise solidaire
d'utilité sociale etus de continuer à
bénéficier de l'exonération de la taxe
versement de transport
comme nombre de collègues j'ai souhaité
signer la lendemain déposée par Ronan
cadran qui comme il l'a précédemment
exposé reprend la proposition
exprimée dans le projet de loi relative
à l'économie sociale et solidaire et
exonère les associations et fondations
lorsque celle-ci bénéficie de l'agrément
entreprise solidaire du TT social
actualiser l'article 7 du même projet de
loi
revenir sur cette exonération
mettrait non seulement en péril le
dernier filet de protection des
personnes les plus fragiles mais aussi
la survie des milliers d'emplois dans le
secteur associatif alors je sais dans la
ministre que ce n'est pas dans ce texte
que nous
pourrons trouver forcément la solution
mais il reste quelques mois dans deux
trois mois nous allons dans cet
assemblée et à l'Assemblée nationale
abordée le projet de loi des finances
sur pour la sécurité sociale
au cours du dernier trimestre je
souhaite madame la ministre que
vous puissiez profiter de ce texte pour
revenir sur cette exonération qui a été
supprimée je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je voudrais tout
d'abord vous remercier pour la qualité
des interventions que vous venez de
formuler puisque au fond nous sommes
effectivement aujourd'hui face vous aide
face à un texte qui est un texte
extrêmement important
pour l'action du gouvernement important
pour les engagements qui sont pris
important pour l'avenir de notre pays et
je veux à cette occasion rebondir sur un
certain nombre de points que vous avez
mis en avant et je voudrais saluer la
manière dont Monsieur café a bien mis en
perspective les engagements qui sont les
nôtres et les choix qui sont ceux du
gouvernement en montrant que nous
cherchons à relever les trois grands
défis qui se posent à notre pays la
réduction de la dette et des déficits
publics la restauration des marges et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et le
soutien
pouvoir d'achat des salariés et des
ménages modestes or ces trois défis ont
trop souvent tendance à être présentées
comme contradictoire comme si nous ne
pouvions pas à la fois assumer une
politique de compétitivité en direction
des entreprises une politique de
réduction des déficits qui minent la
crédibilité de nos systèmes sociaux et
une politique en faveur de l'emploi et
des ménages et c'est cette cohérence
d'ensemble que Madame Christiane de
Montet a particulièrement mis en
évidence en rappelant l'engagement qui
est le nôtre depuis deux ans en faveur
de notre modèle social de notre système
de protection sociale et je veux saluer
comme elle l'a fait le choix que nous
faisons d'engagement nouveau en
direction de droit nouveau je ne
reprends pas ce que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire elle a
particulièrement insisté et je leur
remercie sur les droits nouveaux en
direction des femmes pour la prise en
compte par exemple des congés l'éternité
de façon plus globale et plus cohérente
pour ce qui est du départ en retraite
mais je veux vraiment indiquer là que
c'est un choix de ce gouvernement et qui
ne s'agit pas de dire comme je l'entends
parfois que ce serait une pétition de
principe c'est une réalité puisque c'est
droit il se met un œuvre il se sont
mises en œuvre et il y a des femmes des
hommes qui dans notre pays bénéficient
de droits dont il ne bénéficiaient pas
il y a deux ans et je le dis à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui interviennent
pour dire au fond que nous n'aurions
comme ce lignes de perspective que le
soutien aux entreprises ou comme la dit
Monsieur Watrin au MEDEF moi ça n'est
pas le Medef qui me préoccupe ça dépend
le Medef qui dicte la politique du
gouvernement c'est la volonté de faire
en sorte que dans notre pays progresse
les droits et progresse la situation des
salariés or je vous le dis monsieur
Watrin le principal droit auquel les
Français peuvent prétendre
celui du travail et de l'emploi et
aujourd'hui nous avons un déficit
d'emploi dans notre pays et j'ai le
regret de vous dire que là nous avons
une divergence mais c'est pas en
claquant des doigts et en disant qu'il
faut dépenser davantage pour et alourdir
les déficits qu'on va comme par miracle
ou comme par prestidigitation créer des
emplois dans notre pays ce sont les
entreprises qui créent des emplois même
si nous pouvons aussi créer des emplois
public lorsque c'est nécessaire mais
nous avons besoin des entreprises et que
les entreprises s'engagent pour la
création d'emplois sinon tous les droits
que vous pouvez mettre en avant ne
seront que mirage parce que viendra un
viendra un jour où nous devrons
constater que nous ne sommes plus
capables de les financer je veux
indiquer d'ailleurs que nous sommes dans
une logique d'équilibre et c'est pour
cela que je dis à Monsieur Barbier à
Monsieur roche monsieur roche vous
m'appelez Madame le Ministre à longueur
d'un attention et nous nous connaissons
bien nous travaillons ensemble avec
amitié et plaisir mais que diriez-vous
si moi je vous appelais madame monsieur
la sénateur madame je n'oserais même pas
mais monsieur la sénateur donc de grâce
si je dis
concéder moi un petit madame la ministre
ça me fera plaisir et vous en serez tout
à fait content par la même mais donc
j'en reviens à au contenu au point fort
de votre propos qui était de dire comme
Monsieur Kadou d'ailleurs pourquoi
attendre pour mettre en oeuvre les
réductions de cotisations dont doivent
s'acquitter les entreprises nous avons
aujourd'hui
un problème un enjeu de confiance des
entreprises dans notre pays pas
simplement les entreprises françaises
mais éventuellement d'ailleurs les
acteurs économiques de façon plus large
la France elle a des atouts et tous les
éléments tous les ingrédients de la
croissance sont là ce qu'il faut c'est
au fond créer un cadre donné un cadre
stable visible lisible ce qui compte
pour les entreprises ça n'est pas que
dans 15 jours dans trois mois viennent
enfin se mettre en place des baisses de
cotisation c'est que les engagements
soient pris soit tenus et soit voté et
donc le vote de ce texte de loi il a
pour enjeu de donner une perspective et
une lisibilité aux entreprises en
échange de quoi comme je l'ai dit les
entreprises savent ce à quoi elles vont
elles peuvent s'attendre et il leur
appartient évidemment à leur tour de
s'engager parce que le pacte de
responsabilité c'est impact qui unit
plusieurs parties les entreprises
doivent s'impliquer alors Monsieur des
Essarts vous disiez mais au fond tout
cela ne se décrète pas et il faut
pouvoir mesurer les contreparties bien
il y a quelques jours et cela a été
indiqué aujourd'hui même une grande
fédération de notre pays la Fédération
de la chimie à votre s'est engagé dans
un accord dans le cadre du pacte de
responsabilité c'est engagé pour la
création de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'emplois 47000 a-t-elle évalué
au cours des années à venir ce sont des
engagements que prennent les entreprises
et qu'il nous appartiendra évidemment de
vérifier dans d'autres secteurs ce sera
peut-être d'autres types d'engagement
parce qu'il y a les nombres de créations
d'emplois il y a la qualité des emplois
il y a la formation il y a l'accueil des
de d'apprentis et de futurs salariés et
ce sont tous ces enjeux qui comptent
comme l'a dit madame de Montet il est
important que la négociation collective
se saisisse de ces questions et
permettent de faire l'évaluation de ce
qui est engagé
je veux par ailleurs indiqué que cette
exigence de compétitivité qui nous amène
aujourd'hui à proposer un plan un plan à
la fois d'engagement et de contribution
d'efforts collectifs se fait dans un
souci de justice
je ne l'ai sans doute pas suffisamment
souligné et je remercie monsieur le
rapporteur général de Dini d'avoir
indiqué que nous avons fait le choix
assumer de ne pas mettre à contribution
les Français les plus modestes pas
simplement ceux qui sont en situation de
précarité et non seulement le plan
pauvreté sera maintenu et évidemment ces
personnes les personnes concernées ne
seront pas mises à contribution mais les
Français modestes ne sont pas concernés
par les efforts qui sont demandés et je
veux redire que même si je ne conteste
pas
que les retraités de notre pays soient
mises à contribution les plus modestes
d'entre eux ne sont pas concernés comme
l'a dit madame de montest il y a des
retraités en situation de fragilité dans
notre pays c'est ce dont c'est ce que
montre le fond de solidarité vieillesse
et nous y sommes attentifs et Monsieur
daudini à lui aussi mis l'accent sur les
mesures qui ont été prises dans cette
direction mais si nous demandons des
efforts à l'ensemble des Français et y
compris au retraités même si nous
laissons de côté les si nous laissons de
côté de l'effort demandez les retraités
les plus modestes je veux dire que il
est normal de demander à l'ensemble de
la communauté nationale à l'ensemble des
Français de participer à un effort
puisqu'effort il est nécessaire de fait
pour les plus jeunes en d'autres pays
pour l'emploi des catégories actives on
ne peut pas considérer que la priorité
numéro 1 c'est l'emploi et l'emploi des
jeunes et estimé dans le même temps
qu'un effort qui est demandé devrait ne
pas concerner les personnes qui sont
retraitées dans notre pays la solidarité
intergénérationnelle à laquelle nous
faisons en permanence référence lorsque
nous discutons des textes sur l'avenir
de notre système de protection sociale
ça ne doit pas simplement être un slogan
pour ceux qui défendent la protection
sociale qui existe dans notre pays ce
doit être une réalité et la solidarité
entre les générations elle suppose que
l'ensemble des générations se mettent
ensemble pour favoriser le retour de
l'emploi le retour de la croissance et
offrir des perspectives à nos
concitoyens les plus modestes je veux
dire à Madame marche un beau que sans
doute nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre des perspectives
différentes ou des perspectives de long
terme peuvent s'offrir en matière de
santé ces perspectives de long terme je
les défends et j'aurai l'occasion j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire j'aurai
l'occasion dans des battre avec vous à
l'occasion de la loi de santé mais par
définition des réformes qui portent sur
le long terme ne produisent pas des
économies immédiates et nous devons donc
réfléchir à la manière d'organiser notre
système de santé
différemment qui produisent des effets
assez rapidement et je sais que vous
serez d'accord d'ailleurs pour
considérer que certaines des mesures qui
seront portées dans les textes des
années prochaines sont des mesures qui
doivent être défendues comme la
pertinence la vérification l'évaluation
des actes médicaux par exemple mais
laissez-moi vous dire madame la
sénatrice que si je partage ce que vous
dites sur l'accès aux droits sur le la
lutte contre les refus de soins
je ne peux pas partager ce que vous
dites sur la défiance à avoir à l'égard
de la vaccination des études nous en
avons énormément sur les vaccins et il y
a un risque aujourd'hui je veux insister
là-dessus il y a un risque dans notre
pays à avoir des propos de défiance à
l'égard de la vaccination alors que trop
d'hommes trop de femmes aujourd'hui
renoncent à ce vacciner au nom de
considération générale de parti pris
mais mettent en danger non seulement
leur santé mais aussi celle de ceux qui
les entourent
enfin je veux indiquer à Monsieur
kerbraon et à Monsieur la basée que
j'entends leur préoccupations sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire sur les
établissements de santé en particulier
qui appartiennent à ce secteur de
l'activité l'activité privée à but non
lucratif je suis extrêmement attentive
au rôle et à la contribution que
représente ces établissements dans notre
système vous avez vous-même dit
d'ailleurs que certaines des amendements
que vous proposez sont des cavaliers
dans le texte qui est aujourd'hui
examiné donc nous serons obligés d'y
répondre de cette façon là mais je suis
très attentive à la situation de des
établissements de santé appartenant à la
disons à l'hospitalisation privée à but
non lucratif mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est un texte de mobilisation
qui vous est proposé et vient un moment
où lorsque il est nécessaire de faire
appel à l'ensemble des forces de ce pays
pour aller de l'avant il nous faut
marquer de la cohérence et de la
constance il n'est pas tant de reculer
il est temps d'aller de l'avant et
d'offrir une perspective en particulier
au plus jeune générations et c'est cela
la responsabilité à laquelle je vous
appelle
merci Madame la Ministre la discussion
générale est close nous passons à la
discussion de la motion tendante à
opposer la question préalable madame
Isabelle Pasquet et les membres du
groupe communiste républicain et ses
citoyens en déposé une motion distribuée
sous le numéro 66 tendant à opposer la
question préalable au test en discussion
la parole est à madame Isabelle Pasquier
pour la motion
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
pour la seconde fois depuis l'adoption
de la LOLF Assemblée nationale et Sénat
sont appelés à examiner un projet de loi
de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale
lequel est singulier chacun en
conviendra puisque il ne s'agit pas
uniquement de modifier des tableaux
adoptés en loi de finance initiale afin
de tenir compte d'évolution économique
et budgétaire il s'agit en réalité
dactée dans la loi une évolution
politique un renversement de doctrine
si l'on peut débattre du bien fondé des
mesures proposées dans ce pfrs pour 2014
personne ne peut raisonnablement
prétendre que le prétendu pacte de
responsabilité est conforme aux
engagements pris devant le peuple de
France par le candidat socialiste à la
présidence de la République
singulier encore puisque bien qu'il soit
présenté par le gouvernement nous avons
l'impression que ce aide à faire SS puis
son inspiration dans les dogmes libéraux
défendus depuis plus de 20 ans par une
partie du patronat français celle la
plus hostile à la notion de
mutualisation et de partage des
richesses pourtant au cœur de notre
pacte social depuis 1945
incontestablement si le gouvernement a
fourni le papier c'est bien l'encre du
Medef qui est imprimé sur ce projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale
la genèse du pacte de responsabilité
imaginé par Pierre gataz et appelé par
lui pacte de confiance suffit à
confirmer mes propos à tel point mes
chers collègues que le premier ministre
lui-même en visite à Berlin a assuré ce
site la France a engagé des réformes
importantes des réformes de structures
parlant du pacte de confiance et de
solidarité pour soutenir la croissance
il n'a même pas pris la précaution
oratoire imaginée par les communicants
du gouvernement qui pensent qu'en
rebaptisant le pacte de confiance du
Medef un impact de responsabilité du
gouvernement l'assimilation entre les
deux projets ne serait plus possible
malheureusement pour le Premier ministre
les efforts du gouvernement pour
dissimuler la paternité de ce projet
sont gâchés par son initiateur le patron
des patrons qui suite à cet incident
déclaré immédiatement à la presse nous
avons salué le pacte de responsabilité
que nous a servi de président de la
République le 31 décembre et qui était
inspiré je ne le dis pas trop fort du
pacte de confiance que nous lui avons
apporté sur un plateau tout est dit du
moins sur le processus de collaboration
législative entre le gouvernement et le
Medef même les organisations syndicales
qui soutiennent le pacte ont
publiquement regretté de n'avoir pas été
associée à la construction du projet et
de l'avoir appris comme nous tous par la
paroi de presse cur ieuse conception du
dialogue social
pour autant cette méthodologie très
contestable n'est pas la seule raison
qui justifie notre position pacte de
responsabilité et à ce plfs pour 2014
c'est bien son contenu les régressions
qu'ils comportent la pauvrissement et
l'affaiblissement programmé de la
sécurité sociale qui nous conduisent
notamment à considérer que l'adoption de
ce PLFSS serait un nouveau coup porté à
notre modèle social sans assurer la
sortie de crise économique et sociale
que nos concitoyens attendent
impatiemment et si j'insiste sur la
notion de crise sociale c'est que les
observateurs les journalistes les
économistes et d'une certaine manière le
gouvernement ont tendance à ne parler
que de la crise économique oubliant trop
vite combien celle-ci pénalise et
frappent durement les plus modestes les
précaires les retraités les jeunes et
les malades
en effet le dernier rapport de
l'Observatoire national de la pauvreté
de l'exclusion sociale fait apparaître
un accroissement spectaculaire de
inégalités depuis le tournant du siècle
au point que sous l'impulsion d'une
crise économique sans précédent qui
s'apparente à un épisode nouveau dans la
crise du capitalisme financière le
revenu moyen des 20% des Français les
plus riches et qui valaient à 4,1 fois
celui de 20% les plus pauvres en 2000 et
4,6 fois plus en 2011
en disant l'écart s'est creusé de 12%.
ce mouvement d'accroissement
extraordinaire des richesses de certains
et
d'appauvrissement radical d'autres et la
conséquence des mesures prises en faveur
des plus riches par Nicolas Sarkozy et
de l'absence de mesure courageuse contre
le capital et la finance depuis
l'élection de François Hollande des
mesures que par ailleurs nous avions
ensemble socialistes écologiste radicaux
et communiste condamnés au Sénat lorsque
notre hotte assemblée était
majoritairement à gauche et que le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée nationale
étaient encore à droite
depuis c'est les aspirations de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens n'ont pas
changé conduisant d'ailleurs à
l'élection de François Hollande la
présidence de la République les réponses
que le gouvernement leur apporte ont
bien changé plutôt que de s'écraser
l'emploi n'interdisant les licenciements
boursiers vous avez transposé la nuit
qui autorise les employeurs à licencier
pour modifier économique même en
l'absence de difficultés réelles
économiques quant à la formation
professionnelle levier indispensable
pour permettre aux salariés d'anticiper
les évolutions technologiques vous avez
permis aux entreprises les plus grandes
de réduire leur part de financement au
plan de formation il y avait supprimé
une partie de la mutualisation du
financement qui profitait aux salariés
des petits entreprises
plutôt que d'assurer une réforme
solidaire de l'impôt en instaurant une
plus grande progressivité vous avez
maintenu durant un an le chef du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu vous avez
imposé une taxe retraités censée
financer la part d'autonomie mais dans
les fruits sont en réalité détournées de
sa mission première depuis sa création
vous avez augmenté la TVA et soumis à
l'impôt sur les revenus des salariés la
participation des employeurs au
financement des contrats d'assurance
santé complémentaire
plutôt que de garantir le droit à la
retraite pour toutes et tous dès 60 ans
vous avez allongé la durée de cotisation
repoussant là j'effectif de départ la
retraite à taux plein dans le même temps
que vous réduisiez déjà j'ai envie de
dire les cotisations patronales vous
avez repoussé une première fois la date
de la revalorisation des retraites
d'avril à octobre pour au final les
geler aujourd'hui
chacune des mesures que vous avez
consenties aux employeurs chacun de vos
renoncements au profit du monde de la
finance les salariés des familles et les
retraités en en supporter les
conséquences et vous voudriez
aujourd'hui à travers ce projet de loi
de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale que soit amplifiée ce
mouvement mais dans quelle voie si ce
n'est l'impasse libéral dans laquelle la
droite le baron c'est lierre Laurence
Parisot et les Gattaz père et fils ont
conduit notre pays depuis plus de 20 ans
le pacte de responsabilité dont il est
question ici s'inscrit dans la lignée
des mesures d'allègement de cotisation
sociale consenties aux employeurs sur
les bas salaires et que la loi Fillon a
étendue et comme il y a 20 ans patronat
et gouvernement promettent que ces
mesures s'insérer à une nécessaire
réduction du coût du travail seront
accompagnés de contreparties là encore
la technique est rodée souvenez-vous
dans les années 80 Philippe Seguin
ministre de l'emploi et Yvon Gattaz
décidé ensemble de supprimer
l'autorisation administrative de
licenciement l'ancien président du CNPF
affirmant en échange je m'engage à
échéance de trois ans à créer 540
000 emplois trois ans plus tard la
France comptait 200 000 chômeurs de plus
pour s'injustifier le patronat sur
réfugiés alors derrière la crise
économique il ne demande à tonne
l'histoire se répète et comme en 80 les
victimes du sont du côté des
travailleurs par ailleurs la technique
proposée ici à savoir la réduction d'une
partie des cotisations patronales et pas
nouvelles et au regard des évolutions de
la courbe du chômage depuis 20 ans force
est de constater qu'elle n'a pas fait la
preuve de son utilité
tout du moins pour ce qui est comme le
prétendre gouvernement et patron de
favoriser l'emploi et donc de relancer
l'économie
cette politique a toutefois réussi à
réduire considérablement la part de
financement des employeurs à la sûreté
sociale et contrairement au discours
erroné du Medef en la matière le coût du
travail et notamment du financement de
la sécurité sociale ne tend pas
accroître au contraire le poids des
cotisations sociales employeur dans la
valeur ajoutée a baissé de 18,2% en 1992
à 16% en 2006
c'est sans compter les 22 milliards
d'exonérations de cotisations employeurs
consentis chaque année les 6 milliards
du crédit un peu recherche les 6
milliards de baisse de la taxe
professionnelle les 20 milliards d'euros
accordés au titre du cice et pour quels
résultats si ce n'est un Tasman
généralisé des salaires une
paupérisation grandissante des salariés
et un chômage record jamais atteint même
au plus fort de la crise économique
parce qu'il reprend les dogmes du passé
critiquer par tous les observateurs
sérieux y compris la Cour des comptes le
pacte de responsabilité produira
mécaniquement les mêmes effets
il conduira probablement les employeurs
à maintenir les travailleurs dans des
salaires de misère pour conserver le
bénéfice des exonérations de cotisations
sociales et participera même à détruire
des emplois qualifiés et rémunérateurs
la rapporteur du projet de loi de
finances rectificative et une étude du
service de Bercy explique même que la
traduction du pacte de responsabilité
aura un effet récessif conduisant ni
plus ni moins à la suppression de 60000
emplois 60000 emplois en moins
c'est-à-dire autant de salariés privés
d'emploi à indemniser et prestations
sociales à servir en échange d'une
réduction de recettes sociales de
l'ordre de 8 milliards d'euros rien
qu'en 2015 et là encore nous disposons
en la matière d'un recul suffisant pour
bien voir que les mesures d'allègement
d'exonération de suppression des
exonérations cotisations sociales sont
dans les faits inefficaces pour réduire
le chômage
les économistes atterrés ont récemment
rendu public une analyse du pacte de
responsabilité évaluant le rapport
efficacité coûte des allègements Fillon
qui inspirent le pacte de responsabilité
pour rapporter un de ces dépenses au
volume d'emploi créé ou sauvegarder on
peut estimer le coût annuel pour les
finances publiques de chacun de ces
emplois après de
75000 euros un coût exorbitant pour des
emplois souvent ambassade salaire de
qualité incertaine et mis à la
disposition des entreprises privées
cette somme astronomique est à
rapprocher du budget consacré au contrat
aidé
en 2010 ils ont coûté 5 milliards
d'euros pour 500 520
000 contrat conclu ce qui porte le coût
du contrat pour la collectivité publique
et les comptes sociaux à tout juste 10
000 euros on peut faire la même
démonstration avec le cice
l'omcu estimait l'effet sur cinq ans à
150 000 emplois créés pour un coût
annuel estimé à 20 milliards d'euros à
partir de 2014
alors que notre pays connaît une
situation économique douloureuse et que
chaque dépense est compté au point même
d'imposer des mesures injustes et
antisocial comme le gel des retraites il
nous semble au groupe CRC qu'aucune
mesure ne doit être prise si celle-ci
fragilise la sécurité sociale
c'est-à-dire fragilise le seul outil qui
sert encore d'amortisseur social à moins
que l'emploi et la baisse du coût du
travail ne servent à réalité à
dissimuler le projet réel du Medef
validé par le gouvernement de
suppression totale du financement de la
branche famille par les cotisations
sociales cette exigence ancienne du
patronat qui voit dans la suppression de
la branche famille de la sécurité
sociale une première étape de
l'explosion du système tout entier et
déjà bien entamé
et les gouvernements de Jean-Marc
Ayrault Emmanuel Valls Sion contribué en
réduisant par deux fois le taux de
cotisations alimentantes 7 branches une
première fois à l'occasion de la réforme
des retraites en 2013 une seconde fois
dans ce PLFSS pour 2014 pour justifier
cette rupture majeure avec les avancées
contenues dans le CNR celui qui
constitue notre pacte social le patronat
ainsi l'idée que les prestations
familiales seraient sans lien avec le
travail
un argument entendu et assimilé même par
Michel Sapin puisque lorsqu'il était
ministre du Travail il affirmait je le
cite le fait que vous ayez des enfants
n'est pas un lien avec votre travail
donc il n'y a pas de raison que soit que
ce soit financé par les entreprises tout
le monde bénéficie de la politique
familiale le seul critère est d'avoir
des enfants il n'y a pas de raison
qu'elle soit financée principalement par
le travail
et pourtant lorsque l'on se penche sur
les mécanismes de compensation des
allègements consentis aux employeurs sur
la branche famille on s'aperçoit qu'il
pèse majoritairement sur les salariés et
sont précisément précisément en lien
avec le travail et les salaires on y
trouve la Cesse G qui représente 18% de
ses ressources et parmi les autres
impôts et taxes affectés en note que la
plus grosse ressource près d'un tiers en
2010 et tissu de la taxe sur les
salaires c'est-à-dire une taxe qui porte
sur le travail mais à quitter par les
salariés comme le souligne et les
économies s'intérêts une taxe qui porte
sur le travail se substituant donc à des
cotisations sociales employeurs aux
motif affichés que les prestations
familiales ne devraient pas être
financées par des prélèvements
importants sur le travail
cette politique de substitution du
financement des employeurs par les
salariés s'accompagne dans le même temps
d'une remise en cause des prestations
délivrées par la branche famille je
pense naturellement aux modifications
que vous avez apporté au quotient
familial et aux tentations que certains
ont de remettre en cause l'universalité
des prestations familiales piliers de
notre politique familiale et ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui avec la branche famille
n'est que l'antichambre de ce qui se
passera demain l'application totale du
pacte de responsabilité qui permettra
aux employeurs de réduire leur
participation au financement de la
sûreté sociale s'accompagne d'un
corollaire la réduction des dépenses
sociales de plus de 11 milliards d'euros
une réduction qui conduira deux faits à
des mécanismes d'exclusion et de
renoncements aux soins une réduction qui
conduira nos concitoyens adopter pour
des mécanismes de type assurantiel et
commerciaux pour substituer à la
sécurité sociale tant sur la santé
l'assurance chômage que retraite une
réduction qui accroîtra les inégalités
et sociales alors même que les mesures
d'exonération de cotisation sociale
conduiront à la généralisation des
trappes ambassadeurs et donc de la
précarité la voie dans laquelle le
gouvernement et le Medef veulent nous
conduire avec l'adoption de ce plfs pour
2014 pourrait bien être irréversible
elle acte la priorité donnée au capital
contre lui-même elle substitue d'autres
pacte social par impact
d'irresponsabilité c'est pour toutes ces
raisons et non pas pour couper court au
débat ou même pour l'éviter mes chers
collègues que nous avons choisi de
déposer cette notion pendant à opposer
la question préalable et que je vous
invite à adopter
merci chers
je veux tout de suite annoncer ce qui ne
vous étonnera pas que nous ne votons pas
cette question préalable
vous ne nous avez pas convaincu à
l'avalanche d'arguments contraire
critique nous attendons des propositions
soutenables ce texte présenté par le
gouvernement est un texte responsable
car pour nous la responsabilité
s'est engagée notre pays sur la voie de
l'avenir et ses préservé le modèle
social
ce texte est un texte responsable car
pour nous la responsabilité
s'est engager notre pays sur la voie du
redressement économique en privilégiant
l'emploi et la cohésion sociale
nous connaissons l'effet nous sommes
confrontés à une situation de nos
finances publiques très difficiles en
dépit des efforts désengagés et à une
perte de compétitivité dans une
entreprise qui pénalisent l'emploi et
notre redressement économique et
budgétaire depuis 2002 le creusement de
déficits budgétaires à entraîner une
croissance ininterrompue de la dette
nous héritons aujourd'hui de cette
situation et l'Europe impose ces
critères alors nous n'avons pas le choix
la stratégie économique courageuse du
gouvernement vise à inverser cette
tendance
un pacte de stabilité avec la mise en
oeuvre de l'impact de responsabilité de
solidarité doublée d'un plan d'économie
s'impose à nous notamment pour assurer
l'avenir de notre jeunesse et redonner
confiance à nos concitoyens
baisse du coût du travail baisse des
impôts justice dans les économies voilà
les trois piliers de ce texte je n'y
reviendrai pas ils ont été développés
par notre rapporteur mais permettez-moi
de redire que la reprise économique
retour de la croissance sont en effet la
clé d'une baisse durable du chômage afin
de renouer avec la croissance ce projet
ambitionne de redonner à notre tissu
économique la capacité de mieux
affronter la concurrence grâce à
l'engagement du coût du travail et à la
relance de la consommation populaire ne
nous en privons pas
cette démarche marque une véritable
rupture avec la période précédente qui a
vu l'accroissement des déficits tout au
long du quinquennat des dèles
remboursements massifs pour les assurer
ainsi que le démembrement et la
fragilisation de notre système de santé
en général et de l'hôpital public en
particulier pour toutes ces raisons nous
rejetons cette question préalable nous
devons débattre d'un texte qui engage
notre avenir et le débat qui doit avoir
lieu doit nous permettre de préciser un
certain nombre de points et d'améliorer
des dispositifs
je pense notamment à la demande est
posée par notre rapporteur sur le régime
de cotisations applicable aux
particuliers employeurs pour conclure
face à une crise qui perdure et un
chômage de masse qui s'encre il ne faut
soutenir le gouvernement qui se veut
combattif madame le ministre nous l'a
dit en introduction il se veut tenace et
têtu
pour réussir nous avons besoin de
l'ensemble des forces vives en mouvement
nul ne détient la vérité mais notre
jeunesse n'attend qu'une seule chose
qu'on lui fasse confiance pour créer
innover et faire avancer la France je le
redis nous ne pouvons en confirmer un
conformité avec la commission des
affaires sociales que nous prononcez
contre votre question préalable
merci cher collègue
sur le rapporteur général quelle est la
ville de la Commission
ce président merci Madame ministre mes
chers collègues la commission des
affaires sociales donnée il y a bien
entendu un avis défavorable à l'adoption
de la question préalable
merci madame la ministre
le rapport présenté sur le projet de loi
merci Madame amenice quelle est la vie
du gouvernement
j'ai indiqué à l'occasion de ma réponse
sur la discussion générale que il ne
s'agissait pas pour le gouvernement
d'opposer le progrès social le soutien
aux salariés la prise en compte des
enjeux de pouvoir d'achat à la question
de la compétitivité du dynamisme de
notre économie je crois vraiment que
nous sommes là face à un choix majeur
pour l'avenir de notre pays et donc pour
toutes les raisons que j'ai déjà évoqué
évidemment j'appelle à ne pas voter la
motion présentée merci
de vote
je consulte le Sénat sur la question
préalable opposée par Madame Isabelle
parce qu'il est membre du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen je
vous rappelle donc la ville de la
Commission et
défavorable à vie du Gouvernement est
défavorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par article 56 du règlement le
scrutin sera ouvert donc quelques
instants
peut-être ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à posséder au dépouillement
du scrutin
résultat
du scrutin numéro 224 sur la motion
tendont à opposer la question préalable
nombre de votants 345 noms de suffrages
exprimés 208 pour l'adoption 21 contre
187 le n'a pas adopté voilà pour la
discussion générale du budget
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 vous pourrez la revoir à tout
instant sur notre site public sénat.fr
très bonne journée à tous sur notre
chaîne
ils sont descendus les premiers dans la
rue